hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another update of the Twitter $10,000
challenge where the goal is to bring in
ten thousand dollars in new business for
my company only using Twitter and using
a strategy is recommended by Shawn
Moffitt who is at the Shawn Moffitt on
Twitter so we had our first update last
week I was getting started using the
strategies I'm pleased to say that we
already have our first order that's come
in and that's kind of a little shock it
wasn't expecting anything so quick but
it's for twenty five hundred dollars now
the company basically I've been reaching
out to them on Twitter just commenting
on some other stuff they wrote back and
they said they have this event coming up
that they want me to be a part of it's a
brand name company but they were
uncomfortable with me sharing both the
company name and the dollar amount they
said you can either share the company
name or how much you're paying you but
not both because other people are being
hired as well for this event they're not
getting paid as much so they don't want
to ruffle their feathers so I said I
have to put the dollar amount in because
that's what I promise to you guys so I
took a quick screenshot of the contract
that came in so this is March today's
the 27th this was two days ago where
campaigns have to sign and get it back
to them but the compensation is
twenty-five hundred dollars in cash and
then there's five other ways that we
could compensate me mostly in the form
of products and media exposure that they
want me to to have a guess but in terms
of the ten-thousand-dollar challenge the
main goal there was ten thousand dollars
in cash I'm not counting any products or
media exposure or any other benefits
that we're getting this is purely at
least ten thousand dollars in cash and
so will you'll see some of the things
that I'm doing in the future you'll be
to kind of maybe guest the company but
as of right now I can't say the company
name but we're a quarter of our way
through the goal which again happen a
lot faster than I expected but the time
we just kind of worked out so that's how
we how we're doing so far after after
one weekend so not bad again just to
share what strategies what I'm doing and
I've updated it a little bit of my
process this is my homepage dashboard
when I look at every day and on here is
my social media channels and what I do
basically is every day go through some
key accounts so
today is Wednesday so let me pull up the
Wednesday one and it basically pulls in
people who are in my space who might be
potential either connectors or clients
and here are their most recent tweets
and this is something a week custom
coded ourselves to tie into the Twitter
API pulls in their information and the
most recent tweets and then I try to
respond to some of the tweets that
they're posting out and the goal is for
every everybody on my list you make a
list of the top prospects to be in touch
with them at least once per week and so
every day of the week there's a
difference group of people who i quickly
read their tweets and try to get
involved somehow either saying it was a
good post or retweeting or out in my two
cents on it so that's how I got in touch
with that first company and time we just
worked out did they had a project we had
a quick call and within the week really
had a contract there wouldn't want me to
sign but the contract is is set so a
couple examples of how else that's come
up just so you can see this is from
today so into it is on my list should be
somewhere here on my Wednesday list into
it there it is so they wrote this post
about perks that employees perks to make
employees happy that'll have to cost a
lot it was an article from Inc that they
shared and tweeted and I wrote back to
them who love this idea great share guys
and they wrote back you know glad you
liked it Evan so at the start here it's
just create a conversation so looking at
what they're posting trying to get
involved in a conversation recognizing
them and hopefully being on their radar
if you do it enough they're going to
check out your profile see what you're
all about and if they have an
opportunity to potentially work with you
they'll reach out at least this will
happen with the first one so so far so
good I'm not approaching this from a
hard sell perspective saying you know
you guys need to hire me it's just
basically going through trying to build
your relationship be seen as an expert
and have them come to me when they're
ready with a project so that's an
example one thing that's come in just
today just conversation is no deal
that's happened as a result it's just
just building the conversation but a lot
of people do respond to it which is
great this one came in from pay scale
they wrote in asking me if I would be at
the paid paid chat
day discuss his salary negotiation with
the link and I wrote back to say this is
recent this was an hour ago I wrote back
20 minutes ago I only attend these
events when I host them and bring my
audience have a great event throwback no
problem maybe maybe we can get you
involved with the future pay chat thanks
again for the shoutout and I wrote back
sure and so you know maybe that that
evolves into something I don't know but
another example of somebody kind of
reaching out after having a little bit
of communication just via Twitter I
don't know anything really about these
pay chats and what's going to come but
we'll see another one came from cisco
Canada I'm just going through some
examples so you can kind of get the
process down and hopefully do something
for yourself as well I I tweeted out
something to them they wrote back given
your SMB expertise would be interested
in participate in a Twitter chat about
how tech can impact business growth sure
email me with my email so we can set up
a time to talk thanks Evan we'll be in
touch soon soon and i wrote a happy face
back now i haven't heard back from these
guys it's the what's the 27 30 that was
the 21st so why not just write back
something right now did you guys still
want to have that chat and tweet there
you go we are we are prospecting live on
the air here Twitter so that's basically
how the process works so I use this this
every day go through find their most
recent tweets and then most of them
mostly maybe half of them will respond
with a thank you or a happy face or
something like that and sometimes it
develops into a conversation sometimes
it doesn't these are just ones that I
pulled up from today just as an example
but this happens every day as I quickly
send off messages to those accounts and
it doesn't take too long to do I thought
it would take longer but it's actually
pretty quick the other thing that I
started adding doing adding was a
champion of a small business so part of
my homepage dashboard here it says
champion and basically when I click that
what it will do is pull in one of the
accounts that arm tracking and
recognized them as a champion of the day
so it'll be small business champion the
day Bell small business thank you for
everything you do to help entrepreneurs
so just recognizing them giving them a
shout-out one of sean's
commendations for me was to thank people
who follow me back and I like that idea
I thought that there wasn't a really
great way to track who's following you
and who's not following you back when
you have a large accounts such as mine
and there's only a one time thing so
looking at how can I continue to
recognize people on an ongoing basis and
so this is a new idea we came up with
it's creating that champion of the day
and just recognizing some of the
accounts that I'm I'm tracking and
thanking them for their contribution to
the community so whoever it is that
you're trying to track and get in front
of if you complement them and give them
a shout out to your audience and if you
do that an ongoing basis as well as
being involved in in their tweets
they're likely to take notice of you
look at your profile right back to you
and if there's an opportunity hopefully
do some work with you so I do one of
these every day on top of doing those
regular tweets to the main accounts and
so far people just responded it's been
great so we did one recently this was
with Microsoft they were back many
thanks you kind sir and so you know it
hasn't led to a sale yet but it's just
getting on their radar being you know in
front of them and building a
relationship now as they continue to
post I'll write back and hopefully as
time goes on we'll be able to generate
some business together who knows we'll
see what happens so that's my quick
update I hope you guys have enjoyed kind
of walking through the process is great
that we already have our first sale so
we're quarter of the way through our
goal after one week I imagine is going
to take longer than four weeks to get
through all of it but we'll see what
happens for those are you watching if
you liked the video you want to see more
please give it a thumbs up below let us
know you like this series and you want
to keep on on top of it as we continue
to grow it out and if you have a comment
or question about the video or about how
you're using Twitter to potentially grow
your business myself and Sean will will
take a look at it and try to give an
answer as best we can I also personally
love scene in the comments coming
because it I don't know makes me feel
good when I wake up and see new comments
on YouTube videos about how we're having
an impact so thank you for your time and
we'll see you on the next episode